[Music]
it's been quite a while since we last
covered a Titan and there are plenty
that we've yet to cover so today's video
will be on the original goddess of
childbirth Raya her name itself is
believed to mean ease and flow
symbolizing the eternal flow of
generations and time which is further
highlighted by her marriage to Cronus
the Titan god of time as a deity heavily
associated with motherhood and fertility
some take the flow meaning from her name
to symbolize the flow of birth waters
milk and menstrual blood apologies for
any graphic imagery now you'd assume the
goddess of that time of the month would
be rather cranky but the ease part of
her name symbolizes her comforting
nature rare being one of the original
Titans meant that she was a child of
Uranus and Gaia and once she married
Cronus they became the god and goddess
of the heavens the rulers of Olympus
she's described as given birth to six
splendid children who we know as the
original Olympians
however Uranus and I had prophesized
that these children would one day
overthrow their father
and so Cronus swallowed each one as they
were born first it was Hestia then
Demeter and Hera followed by Hades and
Poseidon a rare of course had one last
child that she would do her best to
conceal from her husband with the help
of her parents they sent her to the
island of Crete where she would stay
until she was ready to give birth to
Zeus once born she would give Zeus to
the nymphs of Mount Aegean where they
would raise him deep inside of a cave
Rhea's cult may not have been the
biggest but she was worshiped in Arcadia
and Crete in the birthplace of zeus when
we see Raya depicted she's often shown
as a woman wearing a turret crown on a
throne accompanied by a lion on each
side of her this association of lions
could also be because the Greeks
identified her with the Anatolian
goddess Cybele II like Raya she was also
considered the mother of gods and at
times seen riding a lion
hence the greeks referring to her as
reyes i billy similar to many of the
other Titans Ria's involvement in the
overall Greek mythos is fairly limited
but she does appear in a few stories
when Persephone disappeared Demeter left
Olympus and refused to perform her
duties
Zeus then called for her return so they
could come to some kind of resolution
but she ignored him it was then Raya who
visited her comforting her and
convincing her that there was no reason
to be angry as she would soon see her
daughter again in some variations Raya
also played a part in helping Demeter
look for Persephone there is also the
story where Raya caught Cronus mid act
during an affair now there isn't a whole
lot to this story Cronus was having an
affair with one of Oceana seas many
daughters when he was caught mid acts by
Raya he then does what any God caught
with his hand in the cookie jar would do
he transforms into a horse and slowly
trots away like nothing ever happened
now what actually happened next your
guess is as good as mine but I think
it's safe to say that that wasn't the
last he heard of it when the Titan
goddess Leto fled to the island of Delos
to give birth to Apollo and Artemis Rhea
was one of the many goddesses present
who went against the word of Hera
helping comfort Leto during the
pregnancy
it's fairly obvious that Raya is another
deity who doesn't really care much for
conflict she seems to be more concerned
in performing her duties and only really
comes out of obscurity to help and
comfort those in need considering that
she was once the queen of Olympus she
seems to have no ill intent towards her
children despite them effectively
dethrone in her we can also assume by
how hard Raya tried to keep her children
away from Cronus that she wouldn't have
sided with the Titans during their
conflict with the Olympians and as a
result it's likely that she wouldn't
have been imprisoned in Tartarus
thereafter which could be why we still
see her in a handful of stories if you
have any thoughts and theories regarding
Raya then feel free to share those in
the comments below if you have enjoyed
the video then please consider leaving a
thumbs up as it really does help me out
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained
[Music]
you